ja so leute ich habe gedacht ich mache jetzt einfach mal stream an ich habe
nichts grossartiges geplant außer ein bisschen china chinesen zeug einzukaufen
bei noch nicht mal zwangsläufig ich muss mal gucken muss gar nicht sein dass
wir das unbedingt in china kaufen china ist ja gerade ein bisschen problematisch
mit versand das soll es nicht das problem habe ich den eindruck die kriegen
es irgendwie gerade nicht hin es gibt zwar neue zollbestimmungen aber habe ich
vertrauen in die chinesischen china chinesen dass die sich da irgendwas
einfallen lassen
würde ich jetzt mal was sagen ich musste heute aber was heißt ich musste
stimmt ja stimmt ja so gar nicht ich habe das sogar so halb freiwillig gemacht
ich war heute zum ersten mal seit ungefähr 500 tagen home office zum
ersten mal wieder für einen normalen arbeitstag auf der arbeit
das war richtig monka es und ich muss euch ich muss euch ich muss einfach
sagen also ich habe jetzt das volle kontrast programm gehabt
oh ja da muss gleich was zu sagen also ich muss sagen was mir heute wieder
aufgefallen ist ins büro gehen ist das unsinnigste überhaupt das ist so ein
das ist so ineffektiv schon ins cyber doc was nee echt gibt so was
das ist immer link posten gucken wir mal das ist so ineffektiv ins büro zu
gehen also einfach aus dem einzigen grund um im
büro zu sein es ist halt keine keinerlei mehr wert du bist also ich bin
insgesamt sagen wir eineinhalb stunden unterwegs also doppelt also nicht
einfach also alle beides ich brauche 45 minuten ungefähr einfach also ich bin
eineinhalb stunden unterwegs die komplett verschenkt sind dazukommt dass
du im büro permanent irgendwelche leute am start dass die rum labern oder im
zweifelsfall das sagen ach ja dann bist ja mal wieder ich wollte dich ja mal
was fragen ich rede ja mit ich rede ja sogar ganz gern mit den leuten aber es
ist einfach extrem ineffektiv wollte beispielsweise heute jemand was fragen
zu zertifikaten die ablaufen in zwei tagen habe ich gemacht hatte mein ja
ja so scheiße wie immer und danach hat er mich über irgendwelche push
notifications auf apple geräten gefragt ich rede ja mit den leuten gerne aber ich
meine es ist halt furchtbar ineffektiv im büro
es ist es ist so langsam auch alles und du hast überhaupt keinen fokus wenn du
so im büro sitzt das ist ganz schlimm ich verstehe die da seins berechtigung
nicht vom ins büro gehen also rein rein jetzt für mich ja ich
sage jetzt nicht dass es jeder so machen soll kann jeder machen wie ich aber ich
ich verstehe ich verstehe ich verstehe also heute habe ich mich wirklich
gefragt wo ist der sinn ins büro zu fahren ich könnte also ich hätte alles
wirklich alles von dem was ich heute gemacht habe von daheim machen können
eine sache vielleicht nicht aber das liegt nicht daran dass sie nur im büro
geht sondern weil es die firma nicht auf die reihe kriegt ordentliche tools zur
verfügung zu stellen aber ich könnte prinzipiell alles ohne
probleme von daheim machen und sogar besser also keine ahnung es hat es hat
heute aus meiner sicht es hat überhaupt keinen sinn gemacht dahin zu gehen nicht
jeder hat einen tollen arbeitsplatz zu hause dann soll er sich den tollen
wenn er von daheim aber sollte tollen arbeitsplatz machen daheim es ist ja
nicht so schwer sich in ordentlichen tische zu stellen ordentlichen stuhl
hinzustellen ordentlichen rechner hinzustellen ordentlichen equipment hinzustellen wenn man
home office arbeiten kann dann verdient man auch geld und kann das machen
ist das bei dir auf der aber mann ich scroll mal kurz und also jetzt mal
kurz vom umut hier zu beantworten die bahn war heute nervig wie immer aber sie
hat nichts verkackt also man musste sich die üblichen
blöden sachen der leute im zug anhören
der zug ein bisschen voll für das dass man einen platz abstand lassen kann
beziehungsweise immer nur einzeln sitzen kann weiß ich gar nicht ob das immer
noch ist ja bahn war nervig wie immer aber
nichts besonderes bahn streikt bundesweit ja so bahn streik leute bahn streik ich
habe ich habe ja heute was zu oft wird da geschrieben das war so ein bisschen im
im rage modus ich glaube dass ich glaube das erkennt man auch ein wenig an
meinem tweet es es ließ sich wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen aggressiver als es eigentlich gedacht war leute leute ich habe ich habe
gegendert in einem tweet wisst ihr warum also erst hat ich mal das problem weil
ich nicht dass ich nicht wusste ob sternchen doppelpunkt leerzeichen oder
groß oder klein aber in dem fall das ist das erste mal in meinem leben dass ich
wirklich einen vorteil durch gendern gesehen habe nämlich nämlich der tweet
wäre sonst zu lang gewesen hätte ich manager und managerinnen geschrieben ich
hätte natürlich auch nur manager schreiben können aber ich wollte
hervorheben dass natürlich die bahn auch so modern ist und sicherlich auch
managerinnen hat dies verkacken wo ich sage ich habe jetzt zum ersten mal
wirklich in dieser eigenen situation hat es jetzt tatsächlich sinn ergeben ok ich
gebe zu der tweet ist ein bisschen fies ja vielleicht vielleicht bisschen
bisschen zu anti bvl stonks manager ich war ich war auch dezent stinkig auf die
bahn heute das habe ich nur geschrieben weil ich habe das letzte mal auch so
was gepostet namens die leute voll aufgeregt deswegen habe ich das noch
mal gepostet das letzte mal habe ich auch geschrieben
suv bestellung ist aufgegeben oder so was oder kam dann auch für die leute
leute max ein suv bestellen ist doch als würde ich mir einen suv deswegen kaufen
denn das ist komplett ausgedingt du musst auf twitter auf twitter musst du
einfach nur die richtigen die richtigen buzzwords schreiben und schon hast du
leute die anfangen nein das geht doch nicht hilfe nee also das ist ich war
deutlich erkannt ich habe zumindest ich war ich war heute echt stinkig vor allem
weil die bahn morgen schon anfängt gut ich meine ich mache ab morgen wieder
homeoffice mich betrifft es nicht aber ich muss ich muss zu dieser ganzen
bahn streitgeschichte mal was sagen korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch liege
also soweit ich das sehe ist das problem ja also was heißt das problem ist die
bahn dass die bahn zu wenig geld bezahlt das ist das grundlegende problem so
wir können mal gucken ob es da vielleicht in guten guten artikel zu
gibt dass jetzt nicht so viel aus dem kopf erzählen erzählen muss welche
welche tagesschau süddeutsche zeitung keine ahnung so tagesschau so also wenn
ich das verstehe also wenn ich den geld schon sehe also das problem bei der
bahn ist ja dass die bahn nicht ordentlich bezahlt so das ist das
grundsätzliche problem aber dieses dieses rumgemache auf twitter
heute wieder ja genau also die haben bei der gdl abgestimmt und 95 prozent haben
gesagt sie wollen streiken und es haben aber glaube ich nur 70 oder so 70
prozent abgeschwitzt aber das ist egal die dürfen dass ich habe prinzipiell
nichts dagegen dass die streiken also die reine die reine die reine aktion dass
die dass die dass die erlaubt ist habe ich nichts dagegen aber was mich auf
twitter wirklich wirklich voll abnervt dass die leute dass die leute so tun als
kannst du quasi trügig ist jetzt am besten aus als als kannst du es
entweder nur gut finden oder du bist ein schlechter mensch so aber dabei ist
die ist die lage doch komplett anders beim bahn streik ich finde das voll und
ganz ok dass die streiken dürfen aber ich muss mich da also die sagen dann
immer so nach dem motto solidarität mit der gdl ein scheiß muss ich ich bin ich
bin solidarisch mit gar keinem der mich davon abhält nicht von a nach b zu
kommen die können mich alle mal am arsch lecken die dürfen streiken das
dürfen sie machen aber deswegen muss ich ja nicht sagen ist das ist das geil ich
bin dafür dass die mehr geld bekommen ich bin dafür dass die bahn die leute
ordentlich bezahlt dass die ihren scheiß zusammen kriegen aber ganz ehrlich der
einzige mit dem ich solidarisch bin in diesem fall ist mit mir selbst ich will
von a nach b kommen die befindlichkeiten der bahn beziehungsweise
dem dem ganzen konstrukt rum sind mir scheiß egal
muss ich jetzt an der stelle mal so sagen ich will dass die bahn ihren job
erledigt die sollen mich halbweg pünktlich von a nach b bringen ich muss
nicht wissen wie viel fünf gewerkschaften daran beteiligt sind wer
aktuell wieder kein bock hat was die bahn manager für eine sache verkacken
das ist mir scheiß egal die dürfen streiken vollkommen in ordnung alles
alles in ordnung die sollen auch mehr geld kriegen habe ich gar kein problem
mit aber ich stelle mich doch jetzt auf twitter hin und sagt solidarität mit
der gdl die können mich alle mal ich will einfach nur von a nach b die
einzelheiten sind mir scheiß egal das ist mir total egal natürlich ist das
eigentliche problem die bahn da sind wir uns ja einig übrigens eine sache wo ich
wo ich auch so meine vermutung habe ist wenn wir nicht noch bei der bahn oftmals
technik hätten aus dem zweiten weltkrieg dann wäre nicht unbedingt
autonomes fahren aber zumindest zentral gesteuertes fahren glaube ich schon
eher ein thema was er theoretisch so als nupp ich habe keine ahnung von zügen
ja aber was ich so als als techniker informatiker nupp so von oben betrachtet
sehe ist ein strecken system mit festen strecken mit festen dingern wo ich immer
weiß wo das ist die man theoretisch auch remote steuern kann wie auch immer und
ich bin mir sicher die bahn will dahin ich glaube nicht dass die bahn noch 20
jahre züge haben oder das weiß man deutschland nicht aber dass die bahn
die nächsten 20 jahre noch züge mit lockführern und und so weit und personal
und sowas haben möchte so und wie gesagt autonomes fahren ist ja irgendwie
blödsinn autonomes fahren würde ja bedeuten man hat ein eine ein zug nimmt
quasi den input von außen und macht dann für sich selbst es ist ja blödsinn die
autonomes fahren ist sinnvoll beim auto wo das eine auto nichts mit dem anderen
zu tun hat aber bei der bahn brauchst du ja kein autonomes fahren in dem sinn
die bahn das ist ein festes streckennetz das sind feste züge das sind gleichen
zeiten da ist nix individuell da ist nicht so wie beim auto dass jetzt einer
sagt ich setze mich ins auto und fahr los und dann ist irgendwie randomness auf
der straße das passiert ja nicht es ist es spawnet ja nicht im hauptbahnhof einen
zug nur weil ich jetzt sage ich will nach hanau fahren der fährt immer
oder auch nicht wenn er nicht fährt muss er kennen was wenn was auf den kreis
noch muss man nicht einfach drüber fahren kein problem juckt mich nicht
so und also im vergleich zu autos müsste das eigentlich mit dem zug doch aus
meiner sicht deutlich einfacher zu gestalten sein dass die ohne größeren
personalaufwand fährt so und was ich worauf ich raus will ist folgendes ich
glaube dass diese ganze geschichte mit in dem zug müssen mehrere menschen mit
fahren wie viel müssen eigentlich einer wie viel ist in so einem cockpit einer
oder hat er irgendwie ein team dabei
weiß ja gar nicht wahrscheinlich einer oder zwei mit ersatz beim größeren
zug wahrscheinlich zumindest was was damit passiert ist dass die bahn
natürlich auch diese sache anstreben wird
die einschlafen geht nicht die müssen ja immer auf den knopf drücken dass die
bahn schneller diese sache mit das ist ja nicht wirklich autonomen fahren wie
sollte man das mal zentral gesteuert im fahren wie auch immer anstreben wird und
sie sich letztendlich ein bisschen selbst den den job abgraben aber auf der
anderen seite macht das auch nichts die haben mehr geld verdient auf jeden fall
und die müssen eigentlich auch extra prämie kriegen bei der bahn dass sie bei
so einem scheiß laden arbeiten und sich permanent dem dem held der fahrgäste
ausgesetzt sehen da müssen die noch prämie für kriegen für diesen kack da
können die ja nichts für es ist ja nicht so dass irgendwie der der lockführer am
bahnhof steht und sagt auch heute fahr ich mal zehn minuten später los habe
keinen bock das liegt an äußeren umständen da kann er nichts für und er
kriegt halt der kriegt halt die die das geflamet der der zug der fahrgäste ab
der der bank manager der bekommt das nicht ab da kriegt es nur über umwege
und ich sage euch leute es ist ein ganz die müssten mal ab und zu an
hauptbahnhof paar bahn manager stellen so kontakt zum zu den leuten was meint ihr
wie schnell andere sachen entschieden werden
wenn die mal wissen wie das ist wenn du von 30 leuten gleichzeitig angeschrien
wirst also da geht es ab die müssten eigentlich auch prämie bekommen dass
dass die für diesen kack für den kackladen arbeiten und die müssen auch
gucken dass die jetzt ordentlich kohle bekommen weil ob die bahn das jetzt fünf
jahre früher oder später forciert durchsetzt durchsetzt sobald die technik
da ist mit mit zügen die zentral gesteuert werden oder autonom fahren das
ist dann auch egal
ja aber ich muss mich hier solidarität und solidarisch mit gar keinem zeigen
die können mich alle mal ich will einfach nur von a nach b kommen was nicht
heißt dass ich dir nicht mehr geld gönne es gibt viele berufe den ich den
ich mehr geld gönne zum beispiel gönne ich auch allen unseren kranken und
alten pflegern kranken schwestern und was sonst auch so alles gibt in der
richtung mehr geld da geht es überhaupt nicht
natürlich gönne ich denen mehr geld vor allem haben sie die haben sie die
alle richtig verarscht die haben sie so krass schiebe das ist der wahnsinn
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern wo wo wo die leute geklatscht haben vom
balkon oder oder wo die wo sie alle erzählt haben oh die frau an der
supermarkt kann es kann auch der mann sein ja die die kassierer innen im
supermarkt das sind alles unsere helden weil die die
weil die das leben am laufen halten und und die alten und kranken pflege sind
unsere helden da haben sie dann da haben sie dann geklatscht am am fenster und
sowas was ein schwachsinn das mag zwar mal ganz nette anerkennung sein aber
ganz ehrlich das einzige was denen hilft ist noch nicht mal natürlich mehr
geld sicherlich mehr geld aber was denen hauptsächlich helfen würde werden
mal bessere arbeitsbedingungen mehr geld ist das eine aber das müsste auf jeden
fall erst mal bessere arbeitsbedingungen geben und bessere
arbeitsbedingungen kriegst du nur durch mehr leute und mehr leute kriegst du nur
durch wenn das ganze ding attraktiver ist du musst mehr leute einstellen du
musst die leute besser bezahlen und du musst die arbeitsbedingungen verbessern
so das geht so alles ein bisschen hand in hand dann hast du auch nicht das
problem weil eine sache werden wir in zukunft definitiv weiterhin brauchen
das sind krankenschwestern das in alten pflege und und solche
geschichten wohingegen wir den lockführer eventuell in was weiß ich 15 oder 20
jahren nicht mehr in dem umfang brauchen aber allen kranken pflege werden wir
immer mehr brauchen nicht weniger wenn du nach japan guckst ich glaube diese
komische robbe kennt ja jeder aber es gibt ja da schon viel mehr tests in
japan in in was was alten und krankenbetreuung durch robberter angeht
also die sind ja da irgendwie 200 jahre voraus wenn man sich das so anguckt aber
ob das da weiß als letzter schluss ist weiß ich auch nicht also da wirst du auf
jeden fall welche brauchen und das hilft doch kein wenn sich die leute da ans
fenster stellen und klatschen wen juckt das denn dass da am fenster einer
gestanden geklatscht hat die sollen da mal ordentlich was springen lassen
die sollen mal gucken dass die dass sich das lohnt das zu machen also ansonsten
muss man sich ja nicht wundern dass das keiner macht mittlerweile hilft ja noch
nicht mal mehr dass man sagt man wirbt leute im ausland an die wollen das ja
auch gar nicht mehr machen da gehst du nach polen und sagst hier
willst in deutschland krankenschwester machen nö gehts immer bloß fort
immer auf klar finden sie immer noch ein paar aber es ist deutlich schwieriger
geworden es ist es ist echt der wahnsinn also
naja so genug gerantet so war mal chat weiter mexikaner war nice ja
ne aber ich nicht
und was soll man damit
also was ist die existenzberechtigung davon was macht er rette der mich aus
in meinem eingestürzten haus das nächste mal oder wie wenn es mal einstürzt
ja keine ahnung zu wie es habe ich heute kein gesehen ja so sieht es aus richtig
hängen geblieben aldo aber alda sagt man nicht mal als digger ist es heute
hängen geblieben hängen geblieben ist es aber tatsächlich aber alda sagt nur
noch ich boom die boomer generation von mir sagt alda
aber ist ist ist ist digger digger ist auch nicht mal angesagt oder oder ist
das ist das noch richtig los digger was sagt man denn jetzt so gerade das
ändert sich doch immer
bruder er auf ehrenbruder basis ja genau diese brudergeschichte das ist was das
nervt mich das muss das muss ich sagen also gegen alda und immer digger finde
ich auch ein bisschen cringe aber aber
diese brudergeschichte finde ich irgendwie bescheuert
jugendwort ist ja 2000 man kann gar nicht mehr warten oder was was ist ein
jugendwort also bruder bruder finde ich bescheuert das hört sich so an wie so
so der ist so dick das ist quasi mein bruder weiß nicht also irgendwie finde
ich finde ich das blöd also wenn man das zu seinem besten freund sagt vielleicht
aber ansonsten ok was ist dann dein jugendwort 2021
bei der weibliche was ist eigentlich mit dem countdown warum ist das warum geht
das hier nicht habe ich das geblockt habe ich habe ich den count das ist
broken wie alt bist du nur bis zehn wirklich
leute mit naja gut zehner klar zehnjährige benutzen das internet guck
mal hier guck mal hier leute ich bin nicht mal etwa hier in dem ich bin jetzt
ja ich kriege 31 plus zur auswahl einfach noch ja guckt euch das mal an
unglaublich danach ist vorbei ok was ist dein jugendwort 2020 das das ist doch
gar nicht neu das gibt es doch dass das haben das haben die das haben die das
haben die bei uns schon gesagt ich weiß bei uns hatten wir hatten wir welche die
haben die schicht haben die gesagt immer das war ich weiß ich glaube das ist es
vermute mal dass irgendwas türkisches oder sowas das haben die ganzen türken
früher in der schule gesagt schüss das heißt so wie oje oje oder so irgendwie
keine ahnung nie sus haben die nicht gesagt schücheln land genau das ist
uralt das haben die wohnschulen gesagt warum ist es jetzt erst jugendwort
ach das kommt jetzt von tiktok ja gut wenn das von tiktok kommt dann ist
natürlich klar dass es aktuell ist wills finde ich gut will mag ich auch lost war
letztes jahr oder lost ist schon wieder haut digger freund kumpel bro ich finde
sogar cool dass das die erklärung dafür ist bro sus
wer will finde ich besser cringe aber cringe ist auch schon brutal warum ist
das jetzt jugendwort das sage ich schon ich glaube jetzt mal ohne scheiß wieder
ein stream ich jetzt vier jahre und ich habe wahrscheinlich in einem der ersten
stream schon gesagt cringe paint champ oder sowas akkurat das ist jugendwort
same aber tastisch oder das klick das sagt doch nicht wirklich jemand das ist
wieder sowas wo wo lang schallt sich ausgedacht hat dass das dass das
jugendliche sagen das sagt doch keiner
was ich schon gehört habe ist dass man zu der rüstung dass man zu den rüstungen
in worson im deutschen papa platte sagt nicht papa latte papa platte für diese
platte die man sich in worson reinschiebt das habe ich schon gehört aber
ansonsten
mittwoch ist es mittwoch ein frosch miem gut pepe geht ja nicht das ist ja
schon white power und so ganz ganz verrufen also wenn ich mir hier was
aussuchen würde dann ist es entweder cringe oder wild also ich würde sagen ich
würde sagen wild oder cringe mittwoch nein
warum darf ich eigentlich für das jugendwort abstimmen mit 31 plus
ach moment das ist gar kein pepe miem das ist das ist low low IQ deutsches miem
ok dann verstehe ich das
geringverdiener das habe ich ja gar nicht gesehen aus dem weg geringverdiener
nee also ich muss sagen von dem was ich von dem was ich da also was ich davon
benutze sind eigentlich nur wild und cringe und ab und manchmal just for fun
sus aber einfach nur dass der chat mal wieder sus schreiben kann ich ich bin ja
ich bin ja ich bin ja für cringe oder ich nehme ich nehme cringe
winch abschicken was jaja abschicken bärere für's voten richtig cringe
na gut guckt mal weiter chat ich bin da wieder total hinten hinten dran
soziale interaktion es ist echt so zumal du ja auch über teams mit deinen
leuten auf auf auf arbeitsbasis sozial interagieren kannst ja ich habe das ich
habe da keine ahnung so zwei drei leute mit denen verstehe ich mich echt gut auf
der arbeit wir schwätzen auch am tag nach irgendwie dem man auch eine halbe
stunde zu über sagen wir so arbeits relatede themen und anderes kann man
auch so machen muss man nicht ins büro fahren
moin betrayed wie one betrayed wenn schon richtig oder oder oder oder wei wei wei
betrayed man weiß es nicht aber auf jeden fall oder ist es betray 3d ich habe
letztes mein teamleiter deswegen angelogen warum wegen was habe ihm
gesagt ich kann nicht ins büro kommen weil ich die zweite corona einfach
bekommen habe und mich deswegen schlapp wurde hat geklappt manchmal je nachdem
wie bei euch so die die die leute drauf sind manchmal haben sie es auch nicht
besser verdient wenn ihr da wenn ihr da so welche habt so nach dem motto nur vor
ort kann man arbeiten dann haben sie nicht besser verdient
ja boilerplate talk genau kennst du das video wo top gear mit autos durch
einen supermarkt fahren nein ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe
auch nie damals top gear geguckt und diese nachfolge show auf amazon habe ich
mal ein paar folgen geguckt muss sagen relativ unterhaltsam so für nebenbei
laufen lassen aber jetzt ist nichts wo ich wo ich da zum stammgucker werden wir
ne top gear ist nicht meins was wird eingekauft noch gar nichts noch ich bin
immer mit dem chat durch aber dann muss ich ein bisschen elektronik kram
einkaufen und oft auf aliexpress mal was schauen
hast doch habe ich habe ich ihr wisst doch was ich für ein auto habe leute
habt das agilste auto auf der welt
das können bloß super agiles kram master fahren dieses auto ich habe einen
opel agila 2001 also ich glaube b oder so heißt das aber so ein auch in grün
genau den hier so sehr gut so glänzend ist er nicht mehr
guck da sitze ich drinnen hinten man sieht das nicht sieht man nicht richtig
das geht nur super agil eitel zertifiziertes kram master der kippt
um in den kurven quatsch der kippt nicht um in den kurven
der sieht so aus ein bisschen ja aber der kippt nicht um in den kurven
und apropos umkippen in den kurven mir fällt jetzt erstmal ein wie boomer ich
bin sagt noch jemandem das wort elchtest was
das war nämlich mein auto von mercedes was umgekippt ist beim elchtest ich
glaube dass ich glaube das ist halt gar keine mehr in begriff
ok ob das die alte a klasse war weiß ich nicht aber ich weiß dass es
irgendwas von mercedes war was bei so einem kurven test umgekippt ist wenn ich
mal in frankfurt bin einen grünen agila sehe dann bin ich das genau gibt
sicherlich nur einen auf der welt in frankfurt
ein in frankfurt
das ist wie gesagt das auto für den agilen cloud netives kram master
das mit der a klasse habe ich nur geschrieben weil das der chat gesagt
hat ich habe keine ahnung davon ich habe von autos generell keine ahnung
interessiert mich auch nicht der arbeitgeber ist verpflichtet die ein
arbeitsrechnung oder laptop zur verfügung zu stellen und weiter machen
sie auch ändert aber trotzdem nichts daran wenn es komische security
vorgaben gibt die einen dran hindern zu arbeiten dass man manchmal nichts machen
kann aber das ist nicht mein problem ich kriege geld auch trotzdem mittlerweile
habe ich dir echt keine schmerzen mehr mit
ich meine ich sage dann was ich bin ja noch so nett und sagt dann wenn was
nicht geht aber letztens habe ich auch wie gesagt mich über bis bisschen
bisschen ausgekotzt das was nicht funktioniert hat ich wäre erst bei meinem
chef der hat verstanden hat ja versteht er ist nicht klingt klingt nicht so
sinnvoll das so zu machen ja dann haben wir so ein security mensch gefragt bei
uns auf der arbeit hat gesagt weiß er nicht genau
dann habe ich noch mal gemeckert dann haben wir den ober security mensch
gefragt den kenne ich da war früher mal bei mir im team und der hat dann halt
gesagt ganz ehrlich hat gemeint er kennt das problem hatte hatte das früher ja
selber und aber wir also sinngemäß hat er gesagt wir sind zu unwichtig es gibt
es gibt ja nur fünf leute die das so machen wollen wir sind zu unwichtig da
gibt es keine lösung für und tut gut da mache ich halt nix easy
da dachte ich mir so im hinterkopf eigentlich dann nicht jedes mal wenn mich
jetzt einer fragt und kannst du da dran weiter bauen wie sieht es mit neuen
import außer kann ichs machen geht nicht hast security mann gehört
was soll ich machen ich würde ja gerne dran weiter
programmieren und dran weiter ist es ja nicht so als will ich nicht
ihr dürft keine selbst gekauften tastaturen auf der arbeit haben ich
finde ich finde security vorgaben auf der arbeit gar nicht doof aber das ding
sieht das sieht echt gruselig aus ich finde so security vorgaben auf der
arbeit gar nicht doof aber ich finde es fängt oft mal an der falschen stelle an
so nach dem motto man hat für produktive server die von außen
erreichbar sind das passwort 123456 und im gleichen atemzug sagt man
mitarbeiter dürfen keine eigenen tastaturen anschließen weil es könnte
ein hardware keylogger drin sein wisst ihr wie ich mein das ist komplett
unverhältnismäßig du hast einen riesen loch auf der einen seite und intern
hinderst du deine leute dran zu arbeiten das widerspricht sich total ich würde
es ja verstehen wenn man alles schon komplett dicht gemacht hat und dann
sagen würde okay die leute können wegen hardware keylogger verdacht keine
eigenen tastatur mitbringen okay ja verstehe ich aber doch nicht wenn wenn
andere sachen das deutlich größere einfalltor sind
ja
doppelpunkt passt ja die sind sich ja nicht einig oder was heißt die man ist
sich auch darf man das sagen man mit einem end also die die bevölkerung ist
sich ja nicht einig so wirklich oder wenn ich gute doch die bevölkerung ist
nicht einig glaube 70 prozent haben da keinen bock drauf aber man liest
leerzeichen sternchen doppelpunkt und großes i und kleines die was ist denn
das für komische musik im hintergrund abfox adventure was hat hardware hat
geantwortet was bei tweet gar nicht das hat nicht das ist nicht gelöscht da
hat jemand darauf geantwortet dass es angeblich die güterzüge nicht betrifft
und da wurde er eines besseren belehrt
jetzt bei der gdl das bin ich bin ich so schlecht ich bin ziemlich langsam mit
dem mit dem chat heute also wenn es nach mir geht wäre pains camp oder bwl stonks
oder stopp entweder pains camp oder stonks mehr nach meiner wenn ich mich
dafür stark machen müsste wir als jugendwort des jahres stonks oder pains
camp weil ich das gerne sage aber sagt niemand der jugendlich ist das wegen hat
es keinen sinn
denkst du starlink wird sich durchsetzen ja aber nicht für das was man
vermutet die sehen ja in starlink so alle internet für die welt das sehe ich
da nicht drin ich sehe das eher als internetmöglichkeit für leute die super
geringe latenz über die gesamte welt brauchen und dementsprechend bereit sind
viel geld zu bezahlen mit dem potent mit dem potential mit dem
potential jegliche weiteren weltraum missionen unmöglich zu machen
es ist verkacken es wird sich auf jeden fall durchsetzen aber wie gesagt nicht
nicht das was man jetzt da sich darunter vorstellt
so ich habe es gleich geschafft darauf eine runde minimetro was ist minimetro
das wäre doch was battlefield 2042 minimetro das ist dann nur die b-flagge
von metro mit direktem spawn neben in dem gang und auf der treppe das als
wäre mit 128 spieler 128 spieler nur metro b-flagge ich sage euch leute es
wird das wird die neue das wird 24 7 rotation das ist das ist das ist quasi
die die killbox und shipment von battlefield metro b-flagge 128 spieler
ah minimetro du meinst dieses das planung spiel ja doch das kenne ich
klar darf ich vote 31 plus
oh meine link auflösung geht nicht mehr achso wo er durch supermarkt fährt
so zammers gleich ja habe ich ja grad schon mein selbst zu abgegeben ja
erst mal die basics machen genau haben wir auf youtube letztes jahr auch schon
gelernt oder war es dieses jahr sogar sich ihre passwörter aktuelle systeme
einigermaßen brauchbare berechtigung ja ich hatte heute wieder ich hatte heute
wieder kontakt mit unserem super ausgeklügelnden namenskonzept ich habe
ich habe aus azure habe ich ja ich kann es jetzt nicht so in ich nicht zu genau
sagen habe ich
hört man das wie könnte man das umschreiben die sourcegruppen abgerufen
und da ist mir aufgefallen dass wir haben das so ein key value store die
value store alter ja so ein key value store wo man
verschiedene informationen über unsere infrastruktur abrufen kann so und da
habe ich heute namen von von von resourcegruppen ab ab abgefragt und da
gibt es ein paar metadata zu leute das ist ein wildwuchs fack es gibt es gibt
einmal leute die schreiben stage development dann der nächste schreibt
staging entwicklung der nächste schreibt environment def so und dann wird
es noch dann wird es noch wilder dann wird es noch wilder
manche schreiben gar nicht das environment dabei sondern schreiben im
titel resourcegruppe minus britt brd darum soll also prd darauf soll man
erkennen ist es produktiv wo ich mir immer denke wer hat sich das ausgedacht
wie soll es da wie soll man da irgendwas einheitliches draus machen das ist
komplett wildwuchs und wir muss sagen wir verwenden auf der arbeit noch gar
nicht so lange als als hosting geschichte oder als cloud anbieter das
heißt man hätte wirklich die chance gehabt das mal ordentlich richtig zu
machen es ist es ist einfach ist einfach der witz ich baue doch jetzt nicht 50
ifs ein bei mir dass ich am ende dann anzeigen kann ok dass damit ist
environment gemeint nur weil es jeder anders schreibt
es aber ist einfach los ist es hat konventionen für die namensgebung von
ressourcen ja das ist schon gut wenn es hat man muss
ich aber auch dran halten außerdem geht es nicht nur um die
ressourcengruppen namen sondern auch um irgendwelche weiß ich habe keine ahnung
wurde das alles hier abfragen sondern auch irgendwelche meta infos dazu
wie gesagt es gibt stage es gibt staging es gibt environment es gibt den namen
von der ressourcengruppe und immer so am meisten hat mich geschockt dass es
leute gibt die nennen es brot es gibt leute in production manche leute
nennen es produktion dann gibt es wieder ganz cool leute nennen es live und da
gibt es die ganz optimierten die nennen es einfach nur p wie das ist doch
komplett also und und natürlich gibt es auch noch also wer den des sich
wieder verbrauchen hat bei uns weiß ich auch nicht
und stream was kann das denn so toll ist
ach leute danke für die saps ich habe noch gar nicht reingeguckt ich schaue
mal kurz dann war dann war mal china china chinesen zeug
sam kardo zwei monate ist am start der leona bomber für 24 zwei jahre alter
nice poggers richtig poggers originale poggers so
den test genau das meine ich den test 1997
das war nix da war elch testes wort des jahres 97 das weiß ich noch
ausgelst testet
heute habe ich einen neuen big scam gesehen sagt der leiko der sagt eine firma friert ich was eine
firma friert ich einen truppes in der hoffnung man kann ich irgendwie dazu das
ganz im monats aber nicht schlecht
das ist ein bisschen da gab es mal irgendeinen film den ich vor jahren
gesehen habe frag mich nicht mehr wie ist das denn mit dem zyntology man
er nicht für drama keine ahnung ich weiß nur noch ich weiß nur noch dass er
dass er am ende vom hoch tom cruise genau dass das am ende ist irgendwie vom
hochhaus gesprungen dann ist er aufgewacht und da haben sie zu ihm
gesagt wir haben sie wieder aufgetaucht oder so gut die ich glaube diese idee
wurde schon öfters öfters ja in ford auch wurde aber auch schon öfters verfilmt
so was in der richtung ob ich die neuen c++ updates gesehen habe auch wenn du
das immer fragst ich würde mal sagen es wird tatsächlich zeit für c++ 2023
wie sieht es denn eigentlich damit aus c++ 23 spam moment ernsthaft
warum gibt es das was ist das nächste 25 24 ok 21 gibt es ne 20 20 gibt 22 23
ok das ist wieder das wieder ein schöner punkt das wäre ein schöner punkt von
c++ wenn du noch nicht mal die feature liste
ordentlich lesen kannst wegen zu viel sonderzeichen und merkwürdigen
dinger dann weißt du mit deiner sprache stimmt irgendwas nicht std ist scoped
inum alles klar stannet zu anter was machen die da für dinger
wisst ihr die bauen so viel sachen in c++ ein ich sage ja gar nichts dagegen
neue sachen einzubauen aber vielleicht sollte man die sprache an sich irgendwie
erst mal benutzbar machen
if konstewal alles klar stannet span wetten das ist was anderes als ich bei
c sharp und als denn als spänz stream stannet out pointer was zum geier ist
das schon wieder stannet out pointer stannet in in out pointer meine gute c
plus plus alda was soll denn das schon wieder sein als diese sprache ist echt
eine ausgeburt der hölle ok c++ reference also ok pass mal auf
wir lesen uns jetzt mal die super aussage kräftige c++ documentation
dadurch durch also stannet in out pointer returns in in out pointer mach
witz da wäre ich nie drauf gekommen
da werde sich wer hätte das nur denken können ok weiter mit mit abgeleiteten
die du die du ist die just was ein wort template arguments that captures
arguments by resetting by reference
moment noch mal noch mal returns deduce template arguments as captured
arguments for resetting by reference
jetzt ist verstehen das wird so ok also return ach ja oh das ist natürlich auch
sehr gut lesbar stannet in out pointer smart p ok das sind das sind das sind
template arguments stannet forward args das ist quasi paar rams aus cbc sharp
pointer ist if pointer ist not same as was ist das überhaupt ich check z plus
plus ist der wahnsinn die buddeln immer wieder neues zeug was man einbauen kann
wohl aber nicht mal klar ist für was es eigentlich da ist jetzt mal ernsthaft
versteht es jemand was für was soll das sein also ich check ich check es
wirklich nicht es ist irgendein neuer pointer typ ok und weiter
habt ihr das jemand von euch und die du ist ja die du ist
beispielkorb ja beispielkorb sehr gut ok example example sample ja nein nicht
autopointer ex alter exa ok ok gibt sich gibt kein example das ist zu obvius da
braucht man kein example für also es ist so offensichtlich dass man da
natürlich kein ne braucht man nicht ist klar ist klar logisch warum findet
er das jetzt noch nicht mal mehr gibt es nicht selbst erklären selbst erklären
ok kein schimmer was aber das ist doch schönes konst ex bill konst ex bill ist
immer compile type compile time das habe ich schon dass das war habe ich verstanden
c++ aha
standard invoke er
was erklärung bis parameter ist in out because you provide a way that's used
insider fallen in der fallschirm ist in die art callback oder was keine ahnung
oh heiße hat ein artikel dazu ok c plus die regel für in out in out
konfium und formen funktionsparameter ok es gab mal es gab mal eine zeit es gab
mal eine zeit da waren funktionsparameter relativ easy
das einfach einen typ angegeben und den dann übergeben alternativ alternativ
nen pointer auf den speicher wo als dieser typ interpretiert wird dann kann
z plus plus irgendwann dabei und hat gesagt wir machen uns doch references ok
aber wozu braucht man diesen ganzen shit überhaupt außer dass es keiner mehr
versteht cheap or impossible to copy echt ich habe keine ahnung was die da
wollen das muss ich mir mal in was zum geier ist was
c++ ist wirklich so die big brain sprache schlechthin und selbst wenn man
biggest brain hat stellt man fest dass total viel uns unüberlegt als fack
ist achso ja da muss ich mal als c++ nur outen ich habe bis heute nicht
verstanden was und und an der stelle bedeutet es gibt irgendwie es gibt
irgendwie left left value right value und und manchmal macht man das und da
vor und manchmal macht man es danach manchmal sogar zweimal keine da ist
selbst rast einfacher ja tatsächlich rast hat eine gewisse logik die einfach
in sich ja geschlossen ist vor in out parameters pass by reference zu non
konst in wie ist das an ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie ist das ganze in
out pointer kommt es hier drinnen vor nee und point keine ahnung c++ ich check
sich ist quasi ein pointer den ich danach nicht ändern dass das eigentlich
nicht mehr ändern kann oder was auch immer ich will es gar nicht verstehen ich
verstehe die ich verstehe ganz ehrlich auch die die notwendigkeit nicht dass
immer immer kommt komplexer und komplizierter zu machen ich meine du
kannst ja jetzt schon alles damit machen die müssten es bloß gucken dass es in
sich irgendwie noch ein bisschen konsistenter wird man könnte man c++
sogar verwenden
aufgabe des tages zwei positive c++ eigenschaften zu zeigen zeigen jetzt nicht
aber ich sagen kann ich welche gibt ein aber als also zwei positive c++
eigenschaften lass mal kurz lass mal kurz überlegen ich meine es ist ja keine
positive c++ eigenschaft dass das einzige was ich dass ich das einzige dass ich c++
benutzen muss weil die plattform die ich mir ausgesucht habe nichts anderes
unterstützt das ist ja das ist ja schon mal kein vorteil also ja performance
würde ich nicht sagen performance ist ist das immer so das offensichtlichste schon
schon in den feature schon in den feature von c++ ok ein c++ feature dass ich gut
finde die compiler fehlermeldung ok lass mal überlegen was was finde ich gut was
finde ich wirklich gut an c++
also ein vielleicht etwas positiver aspekt ist dass sie mittlerweile eine
recht umfangreiche standard library haben die aber auch an inkonsistenzen
inkonsistenzen es fack krankt das ist glaube ich aber jetzt nicht wirklich so
und wahnsinniger vorteil was ist ein richtig gutes c++ feature
jetzt lassen wir mal performance weg was kann c++ so richtig gut wo ich sagen
würde ja das macht richtig spaß dafür c++ oder das in c++ zu verwenden
go hat die beste standard lebt ne finde ich nicht was ist was ich habe keine
ahnung mir fällt nichts ein ok wir fragen mal gut best c++ features
auto was das doch schwachsinn ist auch mittlerweile sogar rausgeflogen 5 best
features c++ ich glaube es gibt keine sprache die komplizierte als c++ ist
popular das aber auch kein feature von c++ was es gibt ich glaube c++ hat
echt keine keine ich meine klar als ist schnell ok was was könnte was ist was
ist ein gutes c++ feature wo ich wirklich sage hey das macht bock in c++ zu
verwenden oder man merkt man hat sich richtig was bei gedacht
ich habe echt keine ahnung also mir fällt echt wenig nix positive
nix positive sein wir fallen nur schlechte sachen ein ok c++ feature was
haben wir ich brauche ein richtig gutes c++ feature was ist ein richtig gutes
c++ c++ durch c bei c wird mir zum beispiel einfallen dass c in sich
irgendwie konsistent und logisch ist c läuft auch auf jeder plattform wobei c++
auch auf so viel ja das ist was doch das ist tatsächlich was c++ läuft so gut wie
auf jeder plattform die sache ist nur die dass c++ ziemliches wir war hat mit
compiler version unterschiedlichen compiler ab wann wie was unterstützt ist
manchmal muss man sagen es ist ein experimental feature manchmal nicht und
nur weil du den standard enables in einem compiler heißt es nicht automatisch
dass der auch alles von dem standard das ist auch so ein unding warum kann ich in
den c++ compiler sagen use c++ 21 und dann sind drei viertel der c++ 21 features
in diesem compiler nicht drin was soll der scheiß das ist auch so was könnte
mich wahnsinnig aufregen so weiter im text most powerful feature ok was sagen
denn diese also ok ein ein ein vorteil ok da lege ich mich jetzt mal drauf fest
ein vorteil ist wirklich es läuft auf so nah zu jeder plattform in irgendeiner
art und weise das heißt aber noch lange nicht dass man seinen code auch auf
jeder plattform kompilieren kann weil wenn ich was halbwegs modernes nehme
weil ich auf dem linux entwickel mit einem aktuellen compiler und sagt dann
hey den part würde ich auch gerne auf vom esp 32 verwenden dann habe ich
erst mal das problem dass vielleicht der der olle wobei so alt ist der ist der
eigentlich gar nicht der hatte zumindest schon 21 features
glaube ich zumindest oder 20 21 gibt es ja gar nicht 20 gibt 20 feature schon
verwenden kann und die man übrigens auch nicht einfach so aktivieren kann
sondern muss dann sagen use c++ zz oder sowas ganz ganz wir ok also es ist auf
jeder plattform in irgendeiner art und weise verfügbar das ist ein pluspunkt
wenn aber auch ein sehr künstlicher zusammen geringster pluspunkt
den fällt auch nichts ein templates na ja ja tatsächlich hey hey mir fällt
was ein leute ich habe ein gutes feature von c++ was mit was ich so in keine
anderen sprache kennen man kann mit template magic ich kann euch ich kann ich
gucke mal ob ich stecke auf der flow finde wie das geht man kann mit template
magic in c++ zur compile zeit prüfen ob ein übergebener string kleiner gleich
oder größer gleich einer eines ja vergleich ist ja tatsächlich das geht
dass das kannst du in kaum einer anderen programmier sprache machen du kannst
runtime überprüfen deine exception schmeißen das geht in jeder sprache oder
crashen du kannst überprüfen ist es ist es das als string typ aber du kannst in
c++ mit templates zur compile zeit test ob du einen zu langen string übergibst
zum beispiel wofür ist das sinnvoll nur mal nur mal als example warum das
warum das tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll ist es gibt zum beispiel beim esp 32 also bei
dem microcontroller die haben eine beschränkung dass du da teilnahmen im
flash also die haben so eine billige filesystem nachbau für ihre 4mb
flashspeicher dass du dass du da teilnahmen nur 21 character lang machen
kannst so und wenn man da jetzt so was bauen will für das esp 32 filesystem
möchte aber compile time safety haben dass niemand quasi dort längere sachen
reinschreibt und es nicht zur laufzeit dann erst crash das geht mit c++ das
fällt mir keine andere keine andere sprache ein aber aber passt mal auf wie
das in c++ geht das ist auch ugly as fuck check string lengths compile time
so alt
was ich weiß nicht mal was ist ich weiß nicht mal was es mir genau sagen soll
aber alles klar das meine ich aber nicht vielleicht muss ich noch parameter
parameter okay ich finde das example nicht aber ich kann euch sagen es geht
in c++ ich weiß dass es in c++ geht weil ich habe selbst mal auf stackover
flow gefunden das hier das hier meine ich das kann man machen also wenn du
checken willst ob ich mein das auch wieder richtig richtig richtig toll
gemacht hier wenn du zur compile zeit checken willst ob dein string parameter
länger als 10 in dem fall ist rust kann das glaube ich auch nicht aber rust
könnte ich mir noch vorstellen dass sie das können ich mein hübsches was
anderes sonderlich aussage aber das ist ok da haben wir jetzt zwei c++ features
die ich tatsächlich ganz gut finde das erste ist ein bisschen an den haren
herbeigezogen dass es auf jeder plattform läuft weil es auch nur sehr
durchwachsen ist mit welchem standard und mit welchen features aber das ist
tatsächlich mein gutes feature also ich würde sagen templates und dass du mit
templates auch coole sachen machen kannst wie zur compile zeit checken mit
einer ordentlichen fehlermeldung ob übergebende parameter in dem fall
zu lang sind nicht erst so das ist ein cooles c++ feature fällt mir keine
andere sprache ein wie das kann so haben wir es ich habe es tatsächlich
geschafft so und jetzt musst musst musst du hast ja schon gesappt muss uns
abgiften wenigstens so also waren wir hier weiter
hey das ist wenigstens noch gleich benannt bei uns heißt das gleiche
environment unterschiedlich von brot bis live bis p bis bis britt
wow poggers fünf abos dankeschön massive subscriptions hier ist jetzt auch
billiger wenn man sich überlegt was quasi ein abo umsonst gekriegt jetzt weil
twitch billiger ist nice huge werden werden glück gehabt
zeigt mal hier das speedfighter robotik jann kreative kreative so an der 7 und
der riesel progas richtig nice
es ist ja nice dass den wescher gefunden hast ok also weiter weiter im text
jsw 7 jungle für den sub ich komme heute nicht hinterher aber heute ist ja eh
entspannend stream aber leute leute höre ich mich so an als ruhig mich gerade
aus sagt mal ehrlich höre ich mich höre ich mich entspannt entspannt
es hört sich vielleicht nicht so an aber ich ruhe mich aus dabei wenn ich
über c++ renten kann ist kein kein problem die stragglers gibt es auch nur
bei c++ ja aber so feine leiser konstrukte und so hast du aber eigentlich
bei vielen sprachen
melnon 234 primes ab dafür den sub was ist ein destructor wenn du eine klasse
anlegst und du willst dass wenn die gelöscht wird noch ein paar sachen
ausgeführt werden davor also wenn die instanz weggeschmissen wird und du willst
dass noch ein paar sachen ausgeführt werden bevor die komplett weg fliegt
dann brauchst du den destructor
hast du entspannt wie klaus kindsky hätte ich jetzt schon ein bisschen rum
geschrien oder sowas in der richtung
auf gar das hatten wir jetzt schon
ich gebe mal ein bisschen schneller
meterlang 99
hör mal auf es muss jetzt nicht sein
ich das mal im daily an ich mache ich mache das als postet auf unser kanban
board gott ich habe ich habe es geschafft gleich gleich fährt der halb
train leute das soll ich mal ein bisschen scam von
twitch ergibt den stream hier auch noch länger das habe ich jetzt auch gelernt
das muss man immer sagen man muss immer sagen durch den support also dass
dadurch dass das streamer support wird kann das stream auch mehr streamen das
sage ich jetzt auch obwohl es bei mir gar nicht stimmt ich sage jetzt einfach
wenn ihr den stream support dann gibt es den stream auch noch länger und und ich
muss den schibet machen den habe ich den versuche immer in videos einzubauen so
nach dem motto ich muss sagen leute schön dass ihr subscribt habt schön dass
ihr auch wieder mit dabei seid und also ich muss quasi den den aktuellen
die aktuellen subscriber ansprechen noch subscriben können und ich muss auch
sagen cool dass ihr das letzte mal subscribt habt und heute wieder mit
dabei seid weil dadurch big brain time habe ich habe ich letztens so eine
psychologische analyse gelesen man muss immer man muss das sagen weil dann die
leute heute subscriben dass sie das nächste mal im video angesprochen
werden als schön dass sie dass du wieder mit dabei bist also die
subscriben quasi schon für die zukunft damit sie das nächste mal direkt
angesprochen werden dass sie wieder schon so lange mit dabei sind richtig
exquisite taktics hier also leute danke für die subs ich bleibe
übrigens noch eine stunde ich gehe jetzt nicht auf oder so danke für die
ganzen subs heute und schön dass auch alle wieder dies letzte mark ist ab
da haben heute mit dabei sind und jetzt kommen wir zu dem what the fuck und
jetzt kommen wir zum sponsor des heutigen videos
raid shadow legends oder noch eine reichheit mache ich nicht
nord vpn nord vpn nein mache ich auch nicht ich habe so viele vpn anfragen so
viele rate shadow legends anfragen was eine zeit lang immer gekommen ist aber
jetzt nicht aber nicht mehr kommt ist world of warships und world of tanks
weiß ich ob es den kram noch gibt aber die die wollen nicht mehr wahrscheinlich
habe ich oft genug gesagt will ich nicht aber das hatte ich vorher früher auch
nie interessiert
das einzige was es bei mir gibt um jetzt mal wirklich echt einen sellout zu
machen wo ihr auch was von habt ausrufe zeichen hetzner im chat
da könnt ihr euch registrieren und eure eigenen linux cloud server holen mit 20
euro startguthaben nur für neukunden mit meinem code und das könnt ihr dann
bestimmt wenn ihr die nur einen von den kleineren linux server nehmt könnt ihr
es bestimmt vier fünf monate laufen lassen bis die 20 euro aufgebraucht
sind
aber wirklich nur kleine
gehen die 20 euro auch für webhosting wenn webhosting bestand von hetzner
cloud ist dann geht es als 20 euro startguthaben ist glaube ich nur für
hetzner cloud only es kann aber auch sein dass es ist auf
dein accountgut schreibt keine ahnung also wer schon immer mal ein bisschen
mit linux rumbasteln will aber ich sage euch wenn ihr anfangen macht haust du
da keine wichtigen sachen drauf aber wenn ihr schon immer mal ein bisschen
rumbasteln wollte mit linux mit einem server mit internet zugang zum beispiel
um zu testen wie macht man das mit zertifikate
ausstellen und sonst was beste variante registriert euch bei hetzner nehmt mal
ein startgutschein und legt euch so eine 2 euro 96 kiste an und bastelt ein
bisschen rum und schmeißt die sache danach wieder weg und das beste ist es
wird stündlich abgerechnet also das heißt selbst wenn ihr eine ultra fette
kiste für 350 euro im monat ein paar bucht weil ihr die rechenpower braucht dann
könnt ihr die einfach zwar ein paar stunden laufen lassen und bezahlt nur
2 euro also das ist richtig gut
nutze ich selbst aha kennst du eine gute alternative
ich wüsste nicht warum man es gibt einige alternativen aber ich wüsste nicht
warum man eine alternative nennen nehmen sollte ab september wird das teurer
stimmt mit ipv4 wird es teurer aber es wird immer noch ziemlich kompetitiv
sein
so ok jetzt jetzt gehen wir mal jetzt machen wir das was ich heute vor hatte ich
kaufe noch ein paar dinge ein das erste was ich mir schon die ganze zeit mal
kaufen wollte einfach weil ich es cool finde und ich nicht nur genau weiß für
was ich brauche aber aber ich finde es nice ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher nach
was ich suchen soll lackierte kabel
ne trete sowas da ich weiß nicht wieder wie nennt man das offiziell
anna anna meld copper wire kupferlack draht exzellent
kupferlack draht genau sowas suche ich kupferlack draht ja aber was dünnes 0,5
sind mir bisschen zu zu pepo fett
was haben wir hier da 10 ist vielleicht ein bisschen dünn 0,28 0,28 erscheint mir
recht recht gut für das was ich machen will
ja keine ahnung ob da jemand von vielleicht jemand schon erfahrung mit
euch ich stelle mir das richtig cool vor denn jetzt mal zur erklärung was das ist
das sind ganz normale kupfer kabel aber die verursachen keinen kurzschluss die
haben ein lack drauf das heißt wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise nehmen LED ich löte
eine led an positiv negativ und dann wickel ich das zusammen so dass es schön
kompakt ist an einer stelle hält und dann gibt es keinen kurzschluss
normalerweise wenn ich plus minus zusammen wickel dann funktioniert das
nicht hier kann ich die kabel quasi aneinander machen und dadurch dass sie
lackiert sind gibt es keinen kurzschluss
dass es nicht heiß werden ja gut das muss aber schon richtig heiß werden
guck mal hier 350 über über 350 grad dass das der lack abgeht aber also die
led was ist das das ist eine led die mache ich an an meinen esp 32
dran das sind dann 3,3 volt und was weiß ich
paar milliampere da wird das nicht so heiß die led vielleicht aber nicht das
kabel
ja da braucht man löte kolben da macht man vorne die lötkolben dran dann geht
der der lack ab und man kann die sachen anlöten so was wollte ich schon immer
haben was man spaz geht weil ich mir das sehr sehr praktisch vorstelle
sind die auch lackiert
was haben wir da noch drinne ja quate habe ich schon alles gekauft
zack zack ja das stelle ich mir wirklich sehr praktisch vor
und nachdem ich jetzt ja eh mein mein stromzähler jetzt mal mit einer
anderen technik auslesen will nehme ich mit der esp 32 kamera ich habe hier so
einen stromzähler ausleser mal gebaut hier im stream haben wir das ja
zusammengebastelt funktioniert hat aber so seine tücken und ich habe mir jetzt
überlegt ich mache jetzt ich lese jetzt direkt mit einer esp 32 kamera den
stromzähler aus und macht dann bilderkennung für die zahlen da gibt es
nämlich ein fertiges projekt auf github das probieren das habe ich euch schon
mal gezeigt das probieren wir dann im stream zusammen aus da kannst du dann
direkt auf dem esp bilderkennung machen ohne blockchain geht auch ohne es gibt
auch sachen die gehen ohne blockchain die der kann zum beispiel hier direkt die
die zahlen darauf erkennen oder er kann auch so nadelanzeigen erkennen wo das ist
ist richtig richtig nice
und da könnte ich mir vorstellen kann ich diesen lack draht besonders gut
gebrauchen weil ich ja auch dann led für beleuchtung dran machen muss ja also
das ist das erste bär haben wir gekauft was brauchen wir als nächstes ich brauche
noch zwei sebaro
das ist ja gar nicht da
amis nein die baro heißen die ich habe gedacht ich kann jetzt ich kann jetzt
jibane aber da ist ja überhaupt nicht mehr da sie baro über schwämmungs
schwämmungs denn so aber nicht für den preis warum ist das jetzt auf einmal so
teuer
what the fuck ich habe das ich habe das vor wann habe ich den gekauft vor zwei
monaten oder so da hat er keine ahnung da hat er 25 ich bin mir nicht sicher aber ich
bilde mir einen hat irgendwie 25 oder so gekostet kann das sein geiz halt mal ist
das jetzt durch die überschwemmung teurer geworden ab 35 ok so und
preisentwicklung
ne reise ok 30 war das kleinste mal
was auch immer da habe ich einen keller liegen und der hat hier unten genau hier
sieht man hier sieht man es gut da hat hier unten so sensoren dran und sollte
es bei mir in keller wasser rein laufen und am sensor vorbei laufen ich meine ich
habe den da platziert wo ich denke dass es am ehesten runter läuft als halt
weil es halt so eine schräge ist ein bisschen runter und hab den unten
hingestellt dann weiß ich dass wasser in keller rein läuft ist schon mal gut
dann kriege ich das wenigstens mit das letzte war ist nämlich beim letzten
starken regen ist nämlich wasser in keller gelaufen und wir haben sich
richtig mitgekriegt
es ist nicht schlimm gewesen weil nicht so viel reingelaufen ist aber gerade da
unten wo heizung und alles steht ist halt doof sobald es an die elektrik dran
kommt also wenn also ich denke mal es passiert normalerweise nix weil die
elektrik bis weiter hoch höher hängt aber es ist auf jeden fall wichtig mit
zu kriegen wenn wenn es im keller anfängt zu überschwemmen und sei so
dass ich die pumpe anschmeißen kann ich habe ja zum passen zum hochwasser habe
ich eine pumpe in keller gestellt habe ich noch übrig so eine kercher
allzweck pumpe mit der kannst du alles pumpen also auch dreckig dreck wasser und
sonst was
nur für den fall der fälle dass es bei uns auch mal wasser im keller gibt
wann kommt das nächste dual video mit dem anders hier wir hatten vor ewig
kein mal geplant was zum hausbau zu machen da muss ich aber auch sagen das
liegt an mir dass das nicht funktioniert hat ich habe ich habe es
bisher noch nicht noch nicht auf die reinkrieg da ist da kann er nix für das
habe ich verkackt
so aber für 41 euro ich mein gucken mal dann sind ja ich habe ja bezahlt ich ja
fast 100 euro mit zwei stück für so zwei publische sensoren das ist mir viel
zu teuer
ja ob das von außen reinkommt oder von der waschmaschine ist doch egal hauptsache
ich will es mitkriegen und ich bekomme es ja mit ich bekomme es einmal mit weil
die dinger haben den lautsprecher das piepst dann und ich kriege über sie
wave eine nachricht geschickt dann sehe ich das auf dem tablet wenn ich auf das
dashboard kucke oder per push notification dass es wasser im keller gibt
ja ich hoffe es funktioniert wenn es wirklich mal drauf ankommt sehe ich
jetzt aber nicht ein ich mache es mal in basket rein aber ich kaufe es nicht
weil ich das für den preis nicht ein sehe ich mein guck mal bei geiz als
kostet jetzt sechs euro weniger aber hatten wir es hier geiz als stadt was ist
denn das stadtwerk am seh das ist das für
das ist doch das gemm seite oder nicht haben im pressum
ne ne ne ne das ist das ist die sind echt
ach das sind wirklich echte stadtwerke die seite ist übrigens prokken die seite
ist prokken
stadtwerk am seh aber die haben das nicht mehr
ausgerechnet den überflutung sensoren haben die nicht mehr na warum wohl war
wohl höhen hohe nachfrage jetzt meins der dark reader ist prokken
jetzt geht es auf einmal ok das ist echte legit seite hätte ich nicht
gedacht
stadtwerke am seh alles klar und danach kommt guck mal die hatten sogar
gratis versand ja da hätte ich mir da hätte ich mir mal ein fünfer park holen
können aber die haben kein gratis versand bei amazon 41 euro also hier hat
sich tatsächlich richtig gelohnt kann man jetzt sagen gibt immer noch kohle
was haben denn die stadtwerke am seh sonst noch so kann man kann man filter
nach händler kann man bei geiz als alles anzeigen lassen was der händler da
gelistet hat wobei ich könnte einfach bei den in the store gucken aber so sehr
interessiert es mich dann doch nicht was csv direkt ist scam warum die haben
ganz gute bewährdung kann eigentlich kein scam sein und die werden es nicht
alles gekauft haben
guck mal die haben ziemlich gute bewährdung und die werden nicht
3445 bewährdung gefakt haben ich glaube da habe ich sogar auch schon mal was
bestellt dreimal falsche lagerbestände gut falsche lagerbestände sind ja nicht
unbedingt scam da kriegst du das geld wieder und gut ist oder sie nehmen es
erst gar nicht an kriegst geld klein wieder
übrigens wisst ihr wer mich wer mich gar maß hat ich habe mir bei richtig
skirmars aber das kriege ich schon auch wieder ich mache paypal paypal kunden
dingsbums fall auf die haben mich gescampt ich habe unterhosen hier
herren unterhosen bestellt bei denen ja und ich habe bestellt zweimal vierer pack
zweimal vierer pack herren unterhosen wo ist es
pass mal auf osen ne wäsche keine ahnung da war es wäsche wäsche herrenwäsche
genau ich habe unter ich habe unterhosen bestellt so was bäms aber stecken die
da was rein in die unterhose dass es dass es männlicher aussieht oder so und ich
habe ich habe zweimal ich habe ich habe zweimal vierer pack bestellt und ich
habe nur ein vierer pack bekommen einfach so
es kam ganz normales paket einfach wie kommt man auf die idee dazu bestellen
ich habe schon mehr unterhosen von denen bestellt aber diesmal haben sie mich
gescampt so habe ich angerufen da muss er da anrufen weil er weil er irgendwie
keine antwortet auf emails und die haben gesagt ja die gibt es gerade nicht mehr
lieferbar und er näher im zulauf und wie weiß ich war nie kommt er gut aber ich
habe sie bezahlt und die war nicht billig ich habe für acht unterhosen 42 euro
bezahlen und ja da hat sie gemeint es kommt bei
paypal zurück und ich warte jetzt schon über eine woche und hast bei paypal
nicht bekommen
wals tonic sagt meine mama holt mir meine unterhosen immer ja ist bei mir
normalerweise auch so aber da habe ich mir mal gedacht ich hole meine
unterhosen selbst und schon funktioniert es nicht
zauerei zumindest haben wir mich voll skamast
mal gucken ob das noch ankommt
wie alt meine mutter ist 71
ich glaube 71 ja doch 71 ja wahrscheinlich
was immer ein jahr älter als das ja sagt drachenlord immer da wer das da
drachenlord sagt dann muss das ja auch so sein
war dein keller schon mal überflutet nicht dass ich mich erinnern kann aber
ich will es auch nicht drauf ankommen lassen deswegen habe ich dazu ein
überschwemmung sensor drin ja ok weiter im text
emerson so haben wir das was brauche ich denn sonst noch ich weiß was ich brauche
da das ist ganz merkwürdig dass da hat amazon irgendwie so ein problem ich habe
jetzt schon mehrfach versucht das hier zu bestellen
das ist knet das ist klebrige knete kennt weiß ich ob das jemand kennt das
ist ich zeige euch mal wie das ist eigentlich recht eine sehr praktische
geschichte als ich ob es an gescheit hier so was da daneben ist das
das maus random kommet kommet aller zeiten so dass es knete die klebt das
ist sehr praktisch erstens kann man wunderbar sachen mit festhalten und
zweitens kann man das sachen mit festkleben so und ich habe das jetzt
schon mehrfach versucht zu bestellen ich kann das bestellen der bestell vorgang
geht durch aber amazon cancel das immer wieder instant ich habe keine ahnung ob
man den kram nicht nach deutschland bestellen darf oder so deswegen habe ich
überlegt übrigens ich brauche nicht das da sind 6666 packs ich weiß dass es da
alternativen gibt euch für das original deswegen habe ich überlegt ich bestell
einfach mal bei bei irgendwie so einem alternativen shop und guckt dann so hier
zum beispiel so beim weil es liefert relativ schnell guck mal ob es dann
ankommt ne das kann ich das kann ich nicht zugelassen sein oder problem aber
du darfst es ja verkaufen aber ich weiß ich weiß nicht warum die das warum die
das
keine ahnung warum die das immer känzeln es gibt keine es gibt keine
benachrichtigung es gibt immer noch ihre bestellung wurde storniert es sieht
tatsächlich es hat ein bisschen was von von call of duty semtex das zeug nur
dass kein plastik sprengstoff ist das ist halt einfach nur klebrige knete ist
die nicht explodiert zum glück
jahu habe ich es richtig gesehen
das ist ja mal boomer kram
ja so sieht das aus man kann tastatur damit sauber machen ok man kann man kann
näh das ist aber ziemlich doof dann hast du das dann demnächst in den ritzen
hängen man kann animals draus machen katzenhaare
entfernen was ja das hält bestimmt ganz toll
richtig pepega video ja super
genau und das wollte ich mir seit einer ganzen weile
what the fuck das wollte ich mir seit einer ganzen weile schon kaufen mal
ein packung davon alter sind diese tipps sinnlos sind die
sinnlos
ok jahu jetzt wissen wir auch warum jahu pleite gegangen ist die sind ja nicht
pleite die stimmt da nicht microsoft hat die akne aber wer hat jahu gekauft
ja wer hat jahu gekauft
ja was jahu sold again genau verizon hat die gekauft und jetzt und jetzt
genau
neun milliarden ist halt auch schon lächerlich wenig im vergleich zu dem was
es mal war
ok jetzt vorbei jetzt haben sie das an irgendetwas in so in so eine investor
gruppe verkauft jetzt ist jetzt komplett vorbei mit jahu rip
immerhin war es vorher schon wer benutzt noch jahu ich glaube in japan ist es
noch recht beliebt ansonsten er braucht so was noch jahu war damals voll beliebt
mit so einem internet katalog das war noch vor suchmaschinenzeiten da
konntest du dann auf der startseite konntest du dann in den internet katalog
durch durch durch forsten ja wollt ihr mal was richtig was richtig boomy
boomeriges hören weil wir es gerade von meiner mutter hatten die hat damals als
wir neu den dsl anschluss bekommen haben das war 7 oder 98 glaube ich 99 so in
dem 38 99 wir hatten glaube ich mit den mit einem der ersten dsl anschlüsse hier
aber auch nur weil ich monat lang bei der telekom genervt habe und mit meinem
vater zusammen damals und die hat sich damals als sie ich habe da so bilden wir
haben ja glaube ich meinen alten computer ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau ist
auch egal die hat sich damals ein buch gekauft bei amazon das internet
verzeichnis oder sowas hieß das das war ein buch ins zwar eine suchmaschine in
buchform was ganz wirres habe ich so noch nie wieder gesehen und ich habe den
sinn auch nicht verstanden
ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden warum er hat das benutzt so so ein buch in
suchmaschine suchmaschine buchform ok weiter was brauche ich dann sonst noch
lasst mal kurz überlegen also kabel habe ich flut sensoren habe ich auch ja die
brauche ich wieder ist fast leer australische barbecue sauce bestie mit
dem krokodil genau die hier beste barbecue sauce leute ich sag es euch
massive ein liter kostet mehr als öl gut öl ist ja auch nicht so teuer im
vergleich zu anderen also mehr als mir fällt kein guter vergleich ein das die
beste barbecue sauce leute beste nicht dieser ganze shit die
originale australien barbecue sauce und was ist es jetzt ist fake
ane das ist das ist hot hot and spicy guan wira was auch immer das ist so ich
habe immer die mit dem krokodil beste ja die sollen mich versponsern sehe ich
auch so sogar mit versand jetzt wird es aber jetzt wird es aber übertrieben ich
bezahle ich bezahle noch nicht sieben euro für eine barbecue sauce und dann
nochmal 3 euro 79 versandt kann das sein dass die gerade sehr begehrt ist dass es
da nirgends wo prime gibt ich meine dann ich guck mal hier würde ich ja über zehn
euro für eine flasche barbecue sauce bezahlen das ist übrigens 10 12 ounces
weil kakona das habe ich also ich habe die ich kaufe die eigentlich immer bei
amazon aber meistens wenn die jetzt nicht vom gas profi 24 kommt
mit schnell australien barbecue sauce genau hier gibt es das für über prime
sonst ja aber kann ich euch wirklich nur empfehlen die ist richtig geil die ist
ein bisschen scharf es gibt bestimmt leute sagen
horny das ist mal zu scharf das halte ich nicht aus das ist aber das ist aber
nicht in die asia chili mäßig scharf das ist gibt der sache guten geschmack
es ist wirklich nicht übertrieben finde ich finde ich super also kann ich wenn es
es mal wieder gibt leute kann ich euch nur empfehlen holt euch mal eine runde
hier original australien hot hot und spicy barbeque sauce
ist hier mal die bewertung durch maggi würze 5,5 kilo
wo ist das problem es gibt bestimmt die ein oder anderen gastronomie dinger die
magge magge würze 5,5 kilo brauchen
jeden morgen ein gläschen
bürtagsgeschenk würde naja also wenn es um bewertung geht da gibt es auch
dieses taschenmesser riesen taschenmesser
nee weiß gar nicht ob es das noch gibt auf amazon
riesen taschenmesser amazon bewertungen das da
das hat auch bewertungen die sind alle die sind alle gebait
das ist schon hart oder
guck mal kriegst du gar eine kiste mit die bewertungen sind halt wieder richtig
richtig richtig gebait so nach dem motto
wir sind wir sind gestern darin eingezogen und so was
so also weiter weiter noch was sinnvolles noch was sinnvolles man so
barbeque sauce habe ich aber barbeque sauce ist zu teuer die kaufe ich nicht
also was brauche ich denn sonst noch barbeque sauce kann ich löschen
ich brauche sfp module keine sfp plus module ich brauche normale sfp module mit
rj45 stecker in meinem server raum gehen die ports aus ich habe nur noch zwei
freie ports am switch
und das sind glasfaser ports 10g also ich habe 12 12 12 10g glasfaser ports ich
brauche aber keine 10g an den ports ich brauche einfach noch ein paar steck
normale gigabit ports so ich habe gedacht ich kaufe mir jetzt irgendwie ein paar billige
paar billige module 21 euro klingt mir doch äußerst sympathisch ja wobei ich die
sachen nicht so diese sachen kaufe ich nicht so gerne auf amazon muss ich sagen
ich kaufe nämlich am liebsten die die ich schon hatte da weiß ich nämlich dass
sie funktionieren und ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher welche das waren wollen wir
mal gucken was es bei aliexpress kostet was mal sfp haben die sowas bei aliexpress
tatsächlich bei aliexpress kostet die hälfte wunderbar sind bestimmt auch super
kompatibel und und gar kein problem aliexpress auf wish nee auf wish kann ich
nicht schon da muss man sich anmelden da kommt noch zoll obendrauf
die jibane schon schon wieder richtig da kommt kein zoll obendrauf die machen das
richtig
versand standard shipping die machen das richtig zehn tage zehn tage lieben die
schicken das aus dem eu wahren lager das mit lehrer das leute das mit zoll ist
nicht so das mit zoll ist zwar auf dem papier so aber praktisch wird es kaum
auswirkungen haben weil die china chinesen hersteller die sind ja auch
nicht doof zoll musst du nur bezahlen wenn ihr das aus china an dich schicken
so was sie was sie aus china machen ist folgendes entweder sie schicken das aus
einem wahren lager nee nee nee diese sache mit ab 22 nein die
freigrenze gibt es noch nicht mehr
so die schicken das entweder aus dem wahren lager in der eu los das heißt es
ist versand eu zu eu das kostet kein zoll oder sie machen big brain time sie
schicken das über die niederlande oder spanien und von dort niederlande nach
deutschland ist auch versand von der eu nach die eu muss auch kein zoll bezahlen
die china chinesen aus china sind sehr schlau was so was angeht die einzigen
die es nicht richtig hinbekommen und kennzeichen sind kakona style aus den
usa
meins kam über belgien musste zoll bezahlen
da bin ich mal gespannt also ich musste noch nie jetzt ohne scheiß ungelungen
noch nie zoll bezahlen bei aliexpress
auch wenn das von china über niederland nach deutschland geht naja die müssen
dass in niederlanden wahrscheinlich dann versteuern aber normalerweise ist von eu
nach eu keine ohne zoll
also ich hatte ohne scheißer ich hatte noch nie und ich habe schon einiges aus
china noch nie ich musste noch nie zoll bezahlen aus china
die ich gehe davon aus dass sie das in den niederlanden da eine abmachung mit
denen haben aber die das eigentliche paket war post nl oder ausgeliefert am
ende hat's dhl
wobei ich ja nicht dafür zuständig bin dass sie das richtig machen
genau die chinesen bezahlen in den niederlanden ok die haben aber
bestimmt mit den niederlanden so eine tolle in eine tolle absprache dass sie
wahrscheinlich weniger bezahlen kein schimmer und wenn es aus dem eu
warenlager schicken ist vorbei dann haben die es irgendwann mal importiert
es liegt darum und nachdem es zehn tage versandt ist ist die chance relativ hoch
dass der artikel standort eben schon hier ist und nicht in deutschland
wir kommen bengut was hat bengut habe ich nie auf bengut alda
sfp was haben die denn zu bieten
du hattest dreimal bei aliexpress das ja ok dann ist aber dann wird es aber echt
also sollte ich probiere das jetzt ich probiere es jetzt mal aus sollte das
wirklich der fall sein dann ist bestellen aus china ziemlich dead was
den chinesen sicherlich nicht gefällt und mir auch nicht
dann nie so was haben die nicht
kostenloser versand sonst aliexpress standard shipping haben die auch was haben
die auch was mit freies verschiffen ok use use
mal gucken was man hier alles zur auswahl hat was ist freies verschiffen
hier drei stück nach aliexpress standard haben wir nur kostenloses verschiffen
standard chip 0w alles klar warum gibt es kein aliexpress priority mehr
also ich bin jetzt wirklich geneigt das auszuprobieren 24 august seit zwei
wochen ja genau so was ich ich würde es jetzt einfach mal ausprobieren bei aliexpress
wenn was soll schon passieren ich weiß man kann es überall aber ich habe sonst
nichts was ich bei aliexpress bestellen würde ich will mal ausprobieren wie es
jetzt mit soll ist wenn ich für 1388 bestell ok bestellen bestellen bestellen
wir halt für bestellen wir halt für für insgesamt 27 euro mal gucken was mal
gucken was dann passiert ich mein mehr als brief vom zoll bitte
nachbezahlen kann es nicht sein und dann und dann würde ich halt mal gucken wie
das jetzt mit china in zukunft laufen soll machst du auch ein unboxing video
was warum von zwei sfp blut von zwei sfp modul scheint bestimmt wahnsinnig
interessant in leipzig flughafen ist der kram aus den usa
ich bin mal gespannt ich bin mal gespannt also ich vermute das kommt aus
dem eu wahren lager wenn die sagen zehn tage garantiert und dann dürfte es
eigentlich kein zoll kosten von eu nach eu wie und wo baut man die ein die
steckt man in den switch rein und dann macht man vorne das netzwerkabel dran
75 tage käufer schutz man sagt jetzt so schnell guck mal die chinesen die
machen das doch eh nicht aber mehr ernsthaft bei aliexpress funktioniert
das tatsächlich ich habe da ich hatte da schon nicht oft aber ein paar probleme
und die haben das besser gehandhabt wie paypal also ich habe den hier als
switch eher 16 x den da also das ist so quasi naja korswitch kann man nicht
sagen so der hauptswitch bei mir der hat 12 10 g sfp plus ports und hier 10 g
kupfer ports aber die sache ist die von diesen ports ich bräuchte da noch zwei
stück und die müssen auch nicht 10 g sein ich brauche einfach noch zwei ports
ja ich habe den damals relativ günstig auch als er noch recht neu war bekommen
im angebot für glaube ich 450 euro oder so das ist richtig guter preis für so
und so und so ein switch
bist du sicher dass die 1g machen ja ich habe da selbst schon 1g sfp module
drin die funktionieren
die gehen das kein problem also davon bräuchte wieder welche aber nur zwei
stück wobei war dabei ich habe glaube ich so gar noch irgendwo welche muss
mal gucken dann bestelle ich da jetzt erst mal
nichts von ich glaube ich habe sogar noch welche für 450 euro hättest du
besser den telekom gaming router bekommen ja das stimmt sachen für katz fps kaufen
die hat ja vor allem angst sag mal gibt es sfp module mit 2,5 g sfp plus mit 2,5
g aber dann billiger als die 10 g ne weil ich kenne nur die die 10 g können die
können dann auch 2,5 aber es wäre doch cool wenn es günstigere gibt die das
das wäre mal big brain marktlücke weil ich habe kein bock 50 60 euro für den
sfp plus modul zu bezahlen die sollen mir einfach den sfp plus
modul geben mit 2,5 und für die hälfte das wäre doch mal was
ich werde sehen ich bestelle bei aliexpress mal und dann ich werde berichten
ne ok ne bestelle ich jetzt nicht kein sfp plus da brauche ich auch ein
direct attach kabel das können wir auch weglassen das muss ich jetzt ja auch
nicht on stream machen was ich noch mal gucken will ich habe
gesehen jelly die mit der bescheuertsten domain aller
zeiten weil eines ihrer hauptvorteil ist dass sie keine cloud brauchen das wusste
ich nicht ich wusste nicht also ich habe das noch nie mit 10 oder 100 g
ausprobiert mbit ausprobiert aber die funktionieren auf jeden fall ich habe
die selbst dran muss übrigens mal chat chat durch scrollen
der lag ist aber leicht beschehen musste aufpassen ja wenn es rauch gibt dann
weiß ich aber lag war beschädigt aber so eklig abrauchen wie der china
spannungswandler wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht
mal hier ich bin total hinten dran
hatten wir schon such mal unify 6 light ab warum sind die super teuer ich habe
überlegt noch mal mal einen sechser sechser ap zu kaufen und in mir hier in
ersten stock zu stellen für mich
wie sind wir gleich von c++ auf barbecue sauce gekommen gar nicht wir haben viele
zwischenschritte dazwischen gemacht ja nee das sagt das erinnert mich ein
bisschen an die restaurants wo das wasser acht euro kostet war ich aus
prinzip auch nicht
kennst du den amazon review killer
nee was soll das sein das klingt wie eine creepypasta oder der amazon review killer
ab und ab heute auftrag sind vier switcher mit insgesamt 16 14 esser für
plusports dazu verkauft wurden für uns von sie ver ich weiß gar nicht wo ich
die am ende alle anstecken soll ja for future use falls was mal das ja
ja aber du kannst usa bestellen kannst du vergessen
gerade dhl in leipzig ist ja kriegst ja gar nicht gehandelt
so habs gleich gut dass wir dass wir jetzt katzen streicheln gif gifs haben
wuppett 2 was ist wuppett ach wuppett ist der keks wuppett 2 eigentlich muss
sie müsste ich jetzt wuppett ketten oder so
da geht vorne feiber rein und hinten kommt kupfer raus
näher nicht wirklich du stöpselst das in den sfp port rein in den sfp port
kommt normalerweise auch kein feiber in den sfp port oder sfp plus port kommt
normalerweise kupfer nein kommt immer in den modul mit kupfer kontakten rein und
auf der einen seite kommt dann entweder ein aion 540 stecker raus oder einen
was ist ein lc sc stecker sc stecker ist es glaube ich für für glasfaser
oder lc
merken ja lc stecker meine ich genau guck so sieht das modul aus wenn da wenn
das für glasfaser ist oder ansonsten ist da ein aion 45 stecker hinten ist das
immer ein modul mit kupfer kontakten also das ist nicht so dass man
glasfaser sachen direkt in den switch stecken würde die einzigen sachen die
man ohne so ein modul in den switch steckt sind direkt attach kabel aber die
haben sowas schon mit dran das ist quasi ein kupfer kabel mit modul hat den
vorteil für kurze strecken ist das viel viel billiger als zwei module und
glasfaser kabel und auch vollkommen in ordnung geht geht glaube ich bis zu 10
meter ganz gut
ist glasfaser wirklich schneller oder hat das einfach mehr bandbreite das
kommt rau an mit was für eine technik man das benutzt
da ich muss dazu ich bin kein netzwerker also du kannst natürlich mit
glasfaser total abgedrehte multiplex in geschichte machen
du kannst über viel größere entfernungen übertragen
die hardware ist billiger bei 10 gigabit das muss man auch mal ganz klar sagen
also sfp plus ports und glasfaser module sind viel billiger als sfp plus ports
und rj45 module die einzelnen ports brauchen weniger strom als mit kupfer
ja mehr fällt mir jetzt grad nicht ein aber ich bin auch nicht der netzwerk
mensch
nichts ist schneller als das licht oder das kommt auf das medium an in dem sich
das bewegt also zum beispiel licht in wakuum versus licht in kunstharz licht
in kunstharz ist bei weitem nicht so schnell wie licht in wakuum
ja ja gut und in glasfasern ist es auch keine lichtgeschwindigkeit weil in
glasfasern das licht das baunst ja ein bisschen hin und her
das geht ja nicht quasi exakt straight das baunst so ein bisschen her und du
musst ja durch das glasfaser durch das ist ja kein weltall wakuum also du bist
du hast keine lichtgeschwindigkeit im glasfaser deswegen sage ich ja auch oder
hab vor jahren schon mal in einem video oder ich sag das immer öfters in videos
auf youtube das und ich weiß noch da kommen immer die big brain leute und
sagen max das kann nicht sein du hast dich verrechnet ich habe ich habe schon
total oft in videos gesagt überlegt euch doch mal wie viel kilometer es nach
china sind ihr könnt gar keinen guten ping nach china bekommen das ist
physikalisch nicht möglich einen guten ping nach china zu bekommen du brauchst
ich sag es jetzt mal aus dem bauch aus ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau
ich glaube dass das das wirklich das die kleinste latenz die du erreichen kannst
nach china und zurück sind glaube ich irgendwas um 50 minisekunden was
natürlich weit von der realität entfernt ist da ist ja keinerlei router
geschichten und auch nicht eingerechnet dass es nur zwei drittel licht
geschwindigkeit im glasfaser hat also du kannst keinen guten ping nach china
bekommen das geht nicht das licht ist zu langsam
für guten ping nach china und das habe ich schon öfters in videos gesagt dann
sagen die leute nein nein nein max das stimmt nicht und da war ich kann mich
noch dran da war irgend so ein big brain typ der gemeint hat so endlich lohnt
sich mal abbie im leistung matte abbie leistungskurs und dann rechnet er
millisekunden mit zehn millisekunden pro sekunde anstatt mit 1000 richtig geiler
abbie matte leistungskurs
oi richtig richtig monat monat s moment
etwa wohl physik nehmen was das hätte glaube ich auch nichts mehr gerettet
bvl denken ne bvl denken also das beste das beste beispiel von bvl denken was
ich kenne ist eine frau braucht das kind neun monate wie lang braucht das kind
bei zwei frauen frage an den chat laut bvl logik braucht es natürlich 4,5
monate was natürlich bescheuert ist und das ist ein super beispiel ist für dass
diese standard rechnung macht mehr leute hin nicht immer funktioniert
ja negativ ping geht nur in stadia negativ negativ ping geht nur in stadia
sonst sonst nicht die haben wir wirklich gesagt sie haben
negativ latencyper stadia
die amis sind einfach nicht schlau nicht das stimmt die china chinesen sind
deutlich schlauer was zoll angeht als die amis zumindest alle alle meine
bisherigen bestellungen haben das what the fuck chain law was ist hier los
was ist hier los
ne kopfer kopfer ist auch nicht lichtgeschwindigkeit im kopfer hast du
irgendwelche elektronen die sich gegenseitig anschubsen
auf low brain niveau wie für mich selbst zu sagen kupferkabel geht es ja geht es
ja durch das also die signale der strom durch kupferkabel die elektronen die sich
gegenseitig anschubsen kupfer gleich schallgeschwindig fachsinn der chat
wieder alter warum ausgerechnet schallgeschwindigkeit ich würde mal
sagen wahrscheinlich ist es auch zwei drittel lichtgeschwindigkeit keine
ahnung signalgeschwindigkeit kupfer ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit strom in
kupfer und ein microcontroller forum das legt sich les ich mir nicht durch okay
jetzt könnt ihr mal das microcontroller forum in in aktionen erleben
ok 0,7 ja da sind wir noch mit zwei drittel ganz gut dabei
geile antwort
das ist das microcontroller forum in reinkultur wieder
drei viertel der lichtgeschwindigkeit ok
drei viertel lichtgeschwindigkeit ab des google weiß bescheid war das gerade
chat wart ihr das das manche hat gerade geplinkt hat slim ontario lange für den
sub ja mit nord vpn ist es noch mal schneller nach china nord vpn umgeht
einfach die lichtgeschwindigkeit kein ding ja quantenverschränkung bringt ja
auch nix weil du damit keine informationen übertragen kannst
heute ist die richtig fife hat time angesagt im chat doch in mess effect geht
das mit quantenverschränkung dann ist alles klar in mess effect die sind ja
aber auch schlauer als wir und und irgendwie was weiß ich 2000 jahre weiter
oder so
ja da finde ich finde ich auch immer ganz ganz schlimm die geht das knall
laufend im server raum ja ganz ganz schlimm
hdmi auf gardener es gibt alles auf gardener ich habe klinke anschluss auf
gardener gesehen ich habe sogar schon so so so normalen schuko stecker auf
karte in gardener gesehen natürlich sind alles jebait dinger aber es glaube ich
immer ganz guter ganz guter gag so chat wir sind nicht weit gekommen es ist es
ist fast bettgetheim fast bettgetheim ich habe es geschafft barbecue sauce nein
noch nicht mal ich wollte eigentlich noch shelly gucken gucken wir gucken wir
morgen weiter leute wir gucken wir gucken morgen weiter
bettge wir haben gestern semper video gehostet hat er irgendwas gesagt hast du
zufällig lust eine probe klausur klausur vor zu programmieren ja welche
welche ja kann man machen so gute idee machen wir schick mal hast du hast gibt
sie irgendwo zu gucken
provider genau also andy wenn du irgendwas hier am start schicken wir können wir
machen man geht es mit dem projekt vom sonntag weiter wahrscheinlich am sonntag
ich war ich bin ich bin ich bin jetzt auch kurz da war jetzt ob der andy noch
was schreibt ja können wir echt machen mache ich dann einem der nächsten
streams muss mir das bloß schicken am besten am besten ach so ok
wirtschaftsinformatik zweites semester java ob ich das kann muss ich mal gucken
ganz ruhig schicken wenn du willst am besten als pdf schickst mir schickst mir
als als upload das irgendwo als pdf oder so falls du es hast und schickst mir an
die an die mail adresse die auf dem channel steht weil ich gehe jetzt auf
aber wahrscheinlich werde ich dir wirtschaftsinformatik in zweites jahr
nicht allzu viel beibringen können hier ohne vorbereitung bei twitter kannst du
es mir auch schicken ist auch ok ja twitter ist auch ok wird da sogar noch
besser ok leute heute horsten wir mal wirklich den cyrus jetzt auch wieder
verdient leute ich gehe jetzt auf wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten mal macht es
gut bettgetime bis denn zu